a judge has permanently blocked Donald
Trump from using military funding to
build his stupid border wall this is
being reported by slate a federal judge
in Texas ruled against Donald Trump
wanting trying to take 3.6 billion
dollars from military construction funds
to build the border wall a permanent
injunction has been made to block Donald
Trump trying to do this or doing it on
the basis that the executive branch
which is where Donald Trump exists does
not have the constitutional authority to
take money that has been appropriated by
Congress the judge in this particular
case was District Court Judge David
Briones a Clinton appointee which of
course is going to be the subject of
Donald Trump and Trump is saying look at
these terrible biased people has made a
permanent what was previously a
temporary injunction from October this
according to The Washington Post is
quote the first instance of a local
jurisdiction successfully suing to block
construction of Donald Trump's border
barrier now there's a few things that I
want to talk about here number one what
we're really talking about here is a
form of theft and I think it's important
to use those terms Trump diverting
military funds that have been
appropriated for the military and using
them for a pet political project that is
a form of theft now is it criminal theft
the type that the police come and arrest
you for and then you know you get
yourself a lawyer and try to get
probation over no it's not that type of
theft but it is a type of theft and we
know that this is the way Donald Trump
has operated in his business career for
a very very long time now if you want to
take the position of we want to support
and defend the military we need to treat
those who choose to serve so that we
don't need a draft well you know all the
stuff that the write claims to want to
do support the troops yellow ribbons and
all of this stuff military spending that
has been debated and a
approved and appropriated it should
actually be used to protect our troops
to protect national security interests
if you believe in American dominance
around the world
that's not my politics but again I'm
thinking of it from the point of view of
a right-winger you would want it used
for that to project power you all this
stuff that right-wingers claim to want
and and and whatever you should be
furious that the president is saying I'm
gonna take the money three point six
billion and I'm gonna build a border
wall particularly when we've seen time
and again that the entire idea of a
border wall to fix the problem of
undocumented immigration is simply a bad
idea from the get-go we have looked at
that in detail when we talk about number
one when if you really want to deal with
the problem of undocumented immigration
then you've got to deal with number one
overstayed visas number two let's deal
with the the proximate causes in other
countries that are pushing people to
want to come to the United States that
would be a far more stimulative use of
money it wouldn't require stealing three
point six billion from the military in
order to build the wall and then of
course you get to the specifics of the
wall you can get a hundred dollar tool
at a hardware store as we discussed and
cut the prototype wall that Donald Trump
thinks is virtually impenetrable you can
climb over it as we've seen done in a
number of viral YouTube videos and then
in the end remember undocumented and
documented immigrants commit crimes in
the United States at lower rates than
native-born Americans even undocumented
immigrants are stimulative to the
economy not only because there are
entire industries that depend on them
including agricultural industry and the
restaurant industry but by virtue of
being here undocumented very often
undocumented immigrants as I've said
before this isn't news are paying in to
welfare programs that they will never
draw money from I'm not cheering about
that I think people who pay in should be
able to draw benefits but that's the
reality
that's stimulative that that keeps that
floats the viability of a lot of these
programs
and on every level the quote analysis of
this issue that we've seen from the
right is completely wrong we are also at
some point hopefully going to see Trump
held accountable by Trump is for the
fact that he didn't build the wall if
the trumpets realize this because you
have two different situations with
trumpets and the wall one is they
believe he's building it Trump has
tweeted dozens of times the wall is
being built it's not there are some
sections of wall that were already there
before fencing that were scheduled to be
replaced and they are being replaced
repaired whatever you would call it so
there are some trumpets who say oh he is
building it now we saw CNN interviewed
six white women without college
education about how Trump is doing for
people who voted for Trump in 2016 and
when at least one of them was presented
with the fact that Trump hasn't build
the wall that's a promise he hasn't kept
she excused it by saying well that's not
because of Trump that's because of
Democrats or something else right so
that that's motivated reasoning to find
someone else to blame for Trump's
failures and I would expect both of
those to play a big role in Trump
retaining a lot of his 2016 support in
2020 let me know what you think about
all of this about the judge's decision
about the wall about Trump voters
thinking he either is building it or
that it's not getting built but it's not
really his fault